for people who want to do something  entrepreneurial how do you start i don't  believe that people are born  meant to be anything we are as humans  the ultimate adaptation machine my goals  mandated that i get good at business you  can't make a racehorse out of a pig but  you can make a really fast pig decide  what your product is take action  immediately make a lot of mistakes  mistakes are going to teach you what you  need to learn and as long as you're not  paralyzed by the fact that you aren't  yet good enough to do what you want to  do and that that's going to be a process  then you'll be fine but you just  got to get yourself moving